اهلا ومرحبا بكم في الدوره السابعه
والعشرين لمؤتمر اطراف اتفاقيه الامم
المتحده الاداريه لتغير المناخ
اسمحوا لي نستهل مهامي كرئيس المؤتمر من
اتقدم اليكم جميعا بالشكر والعرفان على
الثقه التي منحتموها لبلدي مصر
والتي عكسها اختياركم لها لاستضافه هذا
الحدث الدولي الاهم والاكبر على الاطلاق
وانتخابكم ليه لتولي هذه المسؤوليه
الجسيمه التي اطلع بها وكل ثقه في ان مصر
ستجد منكم كل الدعم والتاييد
لنمضي معا نحو تحقيق ما نصبو اليه
واؤكد لكم هنا ان مصر لم تدخر جهدا في هذا
السبيل واننا سنعمله على توفير افضل
الظروف التي تتيح لكافه المشاركين من كافه
الاطراف الحكوميه وغير الحكوميه المساهمه
في انجاح هذا الحدث المهم وضمان خروجه
بالنتائج التي نتطلع جميعا اليها
واسمحوا لي ايضا ان انتهز هذه المناسبه
ليتقدم بعميق الشكر لحكومه المملكه
المتحده الرئاسه السابقه لمؤتمر الاطراف
على كل ما قدمته خلال فتره رئاستها وما
بذلته من جهد لدعم وتعزيز عمل المناخ
العالمي من خلال الاداء المتميز لفريق
الرئاسه البريطاني الذي خاضه صديقي الوزير
الذي صعدته بان عملنا سويا على مدار قرابه
عام كامل لضمان انتقال سلس لرئاسه المؤتمر
يبني علماء تحقق من سياسي في جهاز جو
العام الماضي
ويستكمل المسار نحو الاهداف توافق
توافقنا عليها ونتائج لابد ان نصل اليها
السيدات والساده
اليوم هو السابع والعشرون في مسيره
بداناها معا منذ نحو 30 عاما وهي عمر
اتفاقيه الامم المتحده الايطاليه لتغير
المناخ مسيره متصله اثبتت جدواها واهميتها
عاما بعد عام
استطاعنا خلالها
للخطر الذي يهدد واكثر واعيا بما كشفه لنا
العلم من حقيقه وتبعات هذا الخطر واكثر
اقتناع بما يتعين علينا القيام به من
اجراءات لدار وتغلب عليه اليوم قبل غد
ان مصر عازمته على مواصله هذه المسيره هنا
في شرم الشيخ
هذا نقطه فارغه وعلامه مميزه على طريق
طويل لا يزال امامنا الكثير من الجهد
والعمل نظما وصوله الى وجهته الى النهائيه
ولا نجدد العهد ونرفع الطموح وننتقل بجديه
نحو التنفيذ والتعزيز العمل الجماعي متعدد
الاطراف من خلال التعامل الفعال مع اكبر
تحدي يواجهه البشريه في الوقت الحالي
انكافه الشواهد تؤكد لنا بغير شك ولا جدال
ان تغير المناخ قد اصبح خطرا واقعا يهدد
حياه البشر في كل مكان وبكافه الاشكال
ويؤكد العلم بشكل القاطع ان النمط التنميه
الذي صارت عليه البشريه منذ الثوره
الصناعيه وحتى وقت قريب لم يعد قابلا
للاستدامه
والا الاستمرار على هذا النحو دون تغيير
جذريا سيؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه
تتحملها الاجيال القادمه باكثر مما
يتحملها جيلانا
ورغم كافه الامنيات الطيبه ورغم كافه
الجهود المبذوله
تؤكد الدراسات العلميه مره اخرى من خلال
احدث التقارير الصادره على مدار العام وفي
مقدمتها تقرير اللجنه الحكوميه المعنيه
بتغير المناخ اننا لا نزال نواجه فجوات
تتسع بشكل مقلق سواء فيما يخص الحفاظ على
الهدف الحراري لاتفاق باريس او التكيف مع
الاثار السلبيه لتغير المناخ
او توفير التمويل اللازم لتمكين الدول
الناميه من القيام بدورها في هذا الجهد
والعل ما شاهده على مدار العام من احداث
مؤلمه في باكستان وفي قرتنا الافريقيه وفي
انحاء متفرقه من اوروبا وامريكا لعله تلك
الاحداث وما خلفته من دمار تمثل عباره
عبره
انحاء كوكبنا
يدعونا الى اليقظه والحرص ولا التحرك
العاجل كافه التدابير اللازمه وفاء
بالتزاماتنا وتنفيزا لتعهداتنا
سيدات والساده لا يخفى على احد منا ان
مؤتمرنا هذا العام ينعقد في خدمه سياسيه
تركت اثارها البالغه على دولنا جميعا
ترتب عليها ازمات في امتداد الطاقه
والغذاء
واذا ظل البعض لهذه التحديات من شانها
تعطيل العمل الجماعي الدولي لمكافحه تغير
المناخ انه من المحتم علينا جميعا هنا في
شرم الشيخ ان نثبت عكس ذلك
انني ادعوكم جميعا لانه اكد للعالم اننا
ندرك وحجم التحدي واننا نمتلك الاراده
السياسيه للتصدي له
ومن اجل ذلك فلقد كانت دعوتنا دائما ان
الوقت قد حان للانتقال من المفاوضات
والتعهدات الى مرحله يحظى فيها التنفيذ
بالاولويه
التعجيل بتنفيذ ماترضين عليه في الاتفاقيه
الايطاليه لتغير المناخ
وعززنا في اتفاق باريس وبرنامج العمل
الخاص به مع ضروره رفع مستوى الطموح لكل
الدول وفقا لقدراتها المتباينه بطبيعتها
وهنا يهمني الاشاده بالدول التي قامت
بالفعل بتحديث مساهمتها المحدده وطنيا ومن
بينها مصر
وافقوا انني اتحدث نيابه عنكم جميعا حينما
ادعو سائر الدول ان تحذو نفس الحزم لاسيما
وان التقرير تقييم الصادر مؤخرا حول مجمل
وضع المساهمات المحدده وطنيا كشف ان مستوى
الطموح الحالي لا يرق للوصول الى هدف
باريس
وهنا ايضا تقدر الاشاره الى انه من اجل
التنفيذ الفعال للتعهدات والوعود ان هذه
المرحله من مسيره عملنا المشترك تقتدي
مشاركه اوسع واكثر فاعليه لكافه الاطراف
المعنيه من غير الدول التي اصبح دورها لا
يقل اهميه عن دور الدول وفي مقدمتها
القطاع الخاص والبنوك والمؤسسات التمويل
الدوليه والمجتمع المدني ومجتمعات الشباب
والسكان الاصليين وغيرها
وتاكيدا لذلك فقد حرثت مصر خلال الاعداء
لهذا المؤتمر على التشاور مع هذه الاطراف
واشراقهم في كافه الانشطه والفاعليات
سواء في ما يتعلق بمبادرات دوله الرئاسه
او بالايام الموضعيه المختلفه على مدار
المؤتمر بل وايضا في قمه شرم الشيخ لتنفيذ
تعهدات المناخ التي تبدا اعمالها غدا على
مستوى رؤساء الدول والحكومات
سيدات والساده
ابدا اليوم مسؤوليتي كرئيس المؤتمر لابد
لي ان ادعوكم جميعا الى وقفه للمصارحه حول
حقيقتين لها مناص الى انكارهما وهما اولا
ان جهود ان جهود تغير المناخ على مدى
العقود الماضيه اتسمت بقدر الملحوظ من
الاستقطاب ما افضل الى ابقاء وتيره التقدم
في عمليه التفاوض
ثانيا ان الحاله الرهينه الحشد وتوفير
التمويل المناخ تثير الكثير من الشوارع
اذا نتعاهد توفير المئه مليار دولار سنويا
لم يجد بعد سبيله الى التنفيذ كما ان اغلب
ما يتوفروا من تمويل يميل بطبيعته الى خفض
الانبعاثات على حساب جهود التكيف
فضلا عن اعتماد اغلب التمويل المتاح على
القرود
وظن انكم تتفقون معي اننا لا نملك طرف
الاستمرار على هذا النحو
بل يتحتم علينا تغيير مقتربتنا من التعامل
مع هذا التحدي الوجودي ويتعين علينا السعي
بجده واخلاص للاستماع والتعرف على شواغر
الاطراف الاخرى وتفهمها والعمل على الوصول
الى حلول توفيقيه مقبوله
تكفل تحقيق التقدم وتؤكد بالدليل العملي
مادبا على مناداه به من ضروره الا نترك
طرفا يتخلف عن الركب
رغم جمله التحديات التي نواجهها الا ان
البشريه لا تزال امامها الفرصه لتجاوز هذه
المرحله الصعبه
اثبات الاراده السياسيه لذلك واذا ما
استطعنا العمل سويا بشكل متفق ومتناغم
ونرى يوم الكثير من الشواهد على ذلك فعلى
سبيل المثال يشهد قطاع الطاقه المتجدده
طفره غير مسبوقه ساهمت في انخفاض اسعارها
بشكل كبير كما تطور التكنولوجيا التكيف في
مجالات اداره الموارد المائيه والقطاع
الزراعي بشكل ملحوظ
وشهدت السنوات القليله الماضيه تزايدا
ملموسا في وعي المجتمعات لا سيما في اوساط
الشباب بخطوره تغير المناخ مع عزم اكيد
على التعامل مع القضيه بشكل مبتكر وفعال
ولما بشكل ملموس اهتمام واسهام المجتمع
المدني
ونشطائه والعاملين في مراكز الابحاث
وتزايد دور المراه وتصاعد دور المدن
والحكومات المحليه وغيرها مما يؤكد ان
الفرصه لا تزال ثانيه لوقف هذا خطر الداهم
الذي يهدد معاشه حياه الملايين في مختلف
بقاع الارض
سيدات والساده غدا تبدا قمه شرم الشيخ
لتنفيذ تعهد الماء تعهدات المناخ اعملها
حيث يتوافق قاده العالم هنا للاعراب عن
التزامهم من راسخ بجهود مواجهه تغير
المناخ واولويه العمل من اجل المستقبل
نتمكن فيه من العيش دون خطر وجودي يهددنا
ولا بعد خطوات من تجمع خادتنا نبدا نحن
اسبوعين من المفاوضات والمشاورات الهامه
والحيويه التي يجب ان تجتهد لتخون ميسره
ومنتجه
ادعوكم جميعا غدا الى الاستماع جيدا لما
سيعبر عنه قادتنا واطلب منكم الالتزام
بتنفيذ توجيهاتهم
وترجمه الالتزام السياسي الذي سيتردد صداه
غدا وبعد غد في كافه او رقت هذا المكان
الى توافقات وتفاهمات على النصوص
والقرارات التي نعمل جميعا التي نعلم
جميعا مدى اهميه التوصل اليها من خلال هذا
المؤتمر
اعينكم انما نحن بصدده ليس عملا تفاودا
منفصلا عن الواقع واننا نخسر جميعا ان
ظننا امكانيه تحقيق الفريق لمكاسب على
حساب فريق اخر
فمهمتنا جميعا اكثر نبلا من ذلك
تمتد اثارها لحياه ومعاش ومصالح الملايين
من البشر حول العالم ممن يعانون من واقع
حي تتفاقم وطاته مع كل يوم يقصر فيه في
عملنا او نتباتا وليس هناك مجاله لن نهدر
مستقبل الاجيال القادمه من ابنائنا
واحفادنا فهي مسؤوليه في اعناقنا
انني لا على ثقه كامله انكم تتركون حجم
التحدي وان لديكم العزم والعزيمه على
التعامل مع هذا التحدي بالكفاءه وبروح
التفاهم اللازم لقد حان الوقت للعمل
والتنفيذ
معا من اجل البشريه ومن اجل كوكبنا اشكركم
وتطلع للعمل معكم من اجل مؤتمر ناجح ان
شاء الله شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]